a more striking example should be
familiar to anyone who has grown up in a
Christian society at Christmas we may
express our inner feeling for the
mythological birth of a semi-divine
child even though we may not believe in
the doctrine of the virgin birth of
Christ or have any kind of conscious
religious faith unknowingly
we have fallen in with the symbolism of
rebirth this is a relic of an immensely
older solstice festival which carries
the hope that the fading winter
landscape of the Northern Hemisphere
will be renewed for all our
sophistication we find satisfaction in
this symbolic festival just as we join
with our children at Easter in the
pleasant ritual of Easter eggs and
Easter rabbits but do we understand what
we do or see the connection between the
story of Christ's birth death and
resurrection and the folk symbolism of
Easter usually we do not even care to
consider such things intellectually yet
they complement each other
Christ's crucifixion on Good Friday
seems at first sight to belong to the
same pattern of fertility symbolism that
one finds in the rituals of such other
saviors as osiris Tammuz and Orpheus
they too were of divine or semi-divine
birth they flourished were killed and
were reborn they belonged in fact to
cyclic religions in which the death and
rebirth of the god king was an eternally
recurring myth but the resurrection of
Christ on Easter Sunday is much less
satisfying from a ritual point of view
than is the symbolism of the cyclic
religions for Christ descends to sit at
the right hand of God the Father his
resurrection occurs once and for all
it is this finality of the Christian
concept of the resurrection the
Christian idea of the Last Judgement has
a similar closed theme that
distinguishes Christianity from other
god-king myths it happened once and the
ritual merely commemorates it but this
sense of finality is probably one reason
why early Christians still influenced by
pre-christian traditions felt that
Christianity needed to be supplemented
by some elements of an older fertility
ritual they needed the recurring promise
of rebirth and that is what is
symbolized by the egg and the rabbit of
Easter note concerning the finality of
Christ's resurrection Christianity is
Anna scatological religion meaning it
has a final end in view that becomes
synonymous with the Last Judgement other
religions in which matriarchal elements
of tribal culture are preserved for
example orphism are cyclical as
demonstrated by Ely odda in the myth of
the eternal return New York bawling in
pantheon 1954 end of note I have taken